there's been an awakening
you
hey youtubers is charlie happy 4th
friday well i'm actually posting this on
like a thursday night but maybe it'll be
after midnight so technically fourth
friday if you don't know what's going on
Disney Lucasfilm are just doing a big
unboxing event where they're showing off
toys from Star Wars Episode 7 a couple
of toys actually feature voice clips
from the movie thankfully they're not
spoilery so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to play these audio clips so first
up is Captain phasma that's an
approximation of what she's gonna sound
like in the movie that's actually
Gwendoline Christie voice so the next
step is kylo Ren that's Adam drivers
character I've been waiting for this day
for a long time is it true you just a
scavenger don't be afraid I feel it too
you know what I come for don't fight it
you know you can't I'm immune to the
light that weapon is mine together we
will destroy the resistance and the last
Jedi I think a lot of people were
thankful that he's not using a weird
accent like he's just using his regular
Adam driver voice and the last one is
Finn that's John boyega character named
spinning and I'm in charge now we go
back to jakku we die stay low put up the
seals do you cover quick fn-2187 I don't
know what to do I never to rescue you I
like the shout out to jakku it also
looks like they're giving him some of
the crazy reactions so that's just a
little bit but like they have actual
working bb-8 droids they're really small
I'm like I was Ranger kind of
disappointed I would totally pay more
for a giant version of one of these I
think the thing I'm most excited to buy
or the LEGO sets I try not to buy like
too many toys that I don't have room for
in my apartment hopefully I'll have
moved somewhere bigger by december
because i'm actually planning on buying
a bunch of this stuff i always did like
Star Wars toys more than I like Marvel
and other toys like Marvel DC stuff and
really I actually read more Star Wars
comics as a kid than I did
Marvel and DC Comics the speaking of
which if you guys haven't pre-ordered it
there's a new star wars book that's
going to be cannon to the movies it's
called Star Wars aftermath and it takes
place right after the Battle of Endor
it's all about what happens to the
Empire and how it becomes the new order
and remember the rebellion is being
called the resistance so the book will
also probably address why that is I
don't know if I'm going to do a big book
review on it or anything like that it
depends on how many of you guys get the
book and read it I think they're thought
is is that you'll buy the book and read
it by the time the movie comes out and
it'll lay a lot of the groundwork
there's a whole lot of things going on
in the galaxy whenever episode seven
picks up so if you're keeping tally
there's Star Wars rebels and then
there's this new book Star Wars
aftermath that bridge the gap between
Battle of Endor in the beginning of
episode 7 in fact pretty early on in the
book they actually referenced some stuff
that happens in Star Wars rebels so
there's just another reason to watch the
cartoon I believe that comes back in
October what a prayin up happening is is
is I'll just pick like some specific
things from the book and then talk about
to explain certain things like what's
going on in the galaxy so be sure to
subscribe to get that stuff and if
there's any specific Star Wars videos
that you guys want just let me know
there is a new trailer that we're
waiting for but I'm not expecting that
till like October like later in October
we could get some new footage tomorrow
but the audio clips are the people
talking those kind of like a promo you
could look at it that way I also just
found out that the arrow season 4
trailer is going to post tomorrow I mean
that's that's friday depending on when
you watch this video Friday afternoon so
I'll totally do a video for that
whenever it comes may the force be with
you guys because your cash certainly
will not after tomorrow seriously there
are so many toys they're going to be
selling so well you guys wait for that
you can click here for the last star
wars teaser like the lightsaber teaser
and you can click here to learn about
how captain america civil war almost
cost Marvel Kevin foggy thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tomorrow me me me
me
you